[inaudible]
you all could just say your names and I'm just getting it Mindy's,
although it's not done.
And Chris Pratt look at him.
All right,
so we're going to ask,
well,
we wanna thank you guys for coming to the very center of the nerd universe.
Knock a lot of them out right off,
right out of the gate.
Um,
so we're gonna ask some questions.
okay.
So this,
this movie,
we all saw it.
Uh,
I started last week.
It was amazing.
Really.
It's,
it's,
I would say it's almost like 95% of comedy.
It's really like a fun,
I mean,
the tone is like super light and fun.
Like,
is it hard to keep it loose when you know that it's,
you know,
they're spending like $1 million a minute.
I'm not good with math,
but something like that around the million dollars a second,
I think.
Oh,
sorry.
Um,
have those figures,
you know,
it is,
it is a little difficult juggling tone.
I think when you have comedy and action and drama and all those things in the
same movie,
a lot of times when movies try to have all three of those things,
they essentially fail it all.
Three.
Like,
you know,
movies that are trying to be funny and have action and have drama oftentimes
feel it,
all of those things.
And so,
you know,
it is a little scary because you're there and like,
you're surrounded by alien makeup extras and you're on this amazing set
outdoors,
you know,
it's literally costing at least thousands of dollars a minute if not.
Yeah.
And um,
and they're like,
okay,
no,
do the running man more.
You're like,
oh my God.
Like if this doesn't work,
work,
it's going to be super embarrassing,
you know?
Um,
so,
so it is,
it is a little tough,
but I think tone is something that's like,
we just have to sort of,
we just sort of have to trust James in the post production process that he's
gonna Polish it and test it and make sure that the comedies working but not
overshadowing the action and not,
oh,
not always.
Shining the drama.
I mean,
I like to liken it to like gastronomy,
you know,
like those kind of dishes that shouldn't work together but do and the result of
a chef knowing just how much caviar to mix with the lollipop
and the cat food.
Yeah.
There's a lot of times it is weird when you're like,
oh wait,
now the raccoons crying.
What do we,
uh,
you know,
you right.
And it works,
but it works.
Yeah.
I think,
I think as long as the ingredients are really organic and fresh and new and you
have it in the hands of a good chef,
they can like give you a dish that you're not used to eating,
but you're like,
God dammit.
That's really good.
And I,
you know,
I did not eat
every time.
I'm only use food metaphors,
you know,
I'm hungry.
How many of you a audition for any of these like Superhero,
uh,
huge superhero comic book kind of things before.
And I've been,
you've been in a billion action movies
now.
This is the first,
uh,
the first marvel film,
the First Superhero Film I've done.
And it was like a,
there was like a social media wave to get you involved in a marvel movie.
Was that how this came about?
Yeah,
it happened last year.
Um,
it was at comicon.
I was at comicon and I was there for how I was at holiday h for Riddick and
someone in the iron man outfit ask neutral questions.
How did I envision my relationship with marvel would be,
and uh,
and then the next day Kevin Fygi was there and they asked him the same question.
And then two weeks later,
Kevin,
if I get called,
men said,
you want to play a tree?
To which you said,
I am.
Yeah.
How many,
how many times
did you have to say that?
I mean,
was it like,
hey,
just come in and give a six and then we're gone?
Yeah.
I mean,
the cool thing about the James Gunn is that he really was invested in this
movie.
And I was lucky because they had already shot so much of the movie.
And when I went into the Adr booth,
I was loving what I was seeing.
I was loving these characters.
But you got to play off the scenes that were arguing that tall,
all of them.
So I'm loving star Lord and Loving Gomorrah.
I'm seeing these guys in action.
And I thought that there was only gonna be three words when I came in there and
there was a 50 page document with I am Groot on the lefthand side and then
whatever he wanted to say.
I know some of you,
I mean if this is the nerd capitol,
yeah.
Do you know what a floor colossus is?
And it is a group and essentially people that are familiar with him can
understand him,
but if you aren't familiar with them because he has a hardened larynx,
you can understand the nuance of his speech.
So James Gunn really wanted to give me the line and then the process with trying
to make that line fit into the three monosyllabic words of
so like,
so.
So speaking group,
like say if you wanted to say,
uh,
I'll,
I'll take the check.
How would that sound right
word.
All right.
You gave us one that was,
come on.
What is this?
Um,
Zoe,
you a between star trek,
this an Avatar,
like you're in space more than you're not in space.
Um,
is that something like,
is it hard for you to go like from that to okay,
now you're in Pittsburgh with Christian Bale and it's a serious scene.
Yeah.
Um,
I can't,
I wish I was in space when I went to Pittsburgh.
I know.
No,
no.
The content of what we were doing was so non fun.
When you work,
when you work in a movie like this,
you're kind of skipping to work and you're just sort of bitching and moaning
about the long hours of makeup and the 18 hours shoots or whatever.
When you do a film like out of the furnace,
we can be shooting and in Miami,
in South Beach,
it's still not going to be fun and you're still going to wish that you were in
space.
The content was really heavy.
Nobody made a joke and everybody was like a method actor.
So I'm the only one like walking towards
good.
I like,
instead of being in the makeup trailer and I have like Christian Bale here,
Casey Affleck there.
I'm like,
Hey,
it was just like,
oh my God.
So like,
so it was good when,
after that movie,
you know,
and I was very proud of it.
I side too.
It's good to do things here on earth sometimes.
And um,
cause then when you do get to go one space you're like,
yeah,
we'll start by doing all that stuff with Scifi.
I love Pittsburgh by the way.
You guys have so many awesome bridges and the Andy Warhol Museum is there
by the way.
Don't see in a Miller me please.
But Christian Bale and Casey Affleck nuts.
I'm just kidding.
That was signed by suddenly you've been interested in like we originally we
started out right?
Doing or do you just kind of come to,
you know,
I was,
I,
I grew up in a household where my mother,
if she wasn't watching science fiction,
she was reading it.
And,
and um,
I remember I read Dune when I was very,
very young and I was lady Jessica for many Halloweens.
I was at banner desert.
And um,
so,
uh,
I just,
there was something about the curiosity of what can happen there.
And having a lot of respect through my mother's eyes for the writers and
creators that we're able to imagine the unimaginable.
I just thought they,
it was such a bold decision and,
and,
and they were so they were originals,
you know,
and um,
being an underdog myself,
I kind of felt an affinity always with people that were able to go outside of
the norm and,
and see life for what it truly truly is,
which is a complete blank canvas.
Uh,
so filmmakers like Jj Abrams,
James Cameron,
Steven Spielberg are not people that I would've thought that a girl from Queens
would get to work with.
And the first,
you know,
it's a seven or eight years of my acting career and yet I did.
And,
um,
and I was very grateful for it.
And then I connected all the dots and it has to do with our affinity with space.
And I'm okay with that.
I did have a fear when,
when James Gunn came calling,
they come calling.
I've,
I sorta gone,
I always go,
this will be the last,
and then it's like,
you got,
you got so and so is it.
What do you want?
You're going to be green now instead of blue.
That brings up,
is it hard to play a green person or a blue person?
Well,
because I'm a little,
I'm a little lazy and heart.
Um,
I like motion capture better because you guys get to do all the hard work.
And I just,
I do my work and I,
I put it all out there.
Uh,
but then I walk away and then it's all done in two years.
I can post and things like that.
Uh,
for guardians of the galaxy,
like I have to sit there for five hours and it's not cool.
Like I have add,
I have OCD.
I'm an England,
I'm away from home.
So it's just,
it's been,
it's still dark and you go in and you're getting your makeup done.
You come out and it's still dark,
like the day hasn't even started.
And then you have like 16 hours worth of work to do.
Um,
and you,
you can't complain because everybody's just so happy to be there.
[inaudible] palace.
We were watching it.
We were just,
we were just like,
so does every actor no karate now.
Like it seems like,
did you guys know many martial arts before this or did you have to learn it,
uh,
for the [inaudible] when you were in the booth?
I am doing it for fun.
No,
but I mean it seems like
he goes,
we're doing a lot of lot of martial arts really dumbed down my marsh large
scale.
Yeah.
I'm a 10th degree black belt in every martial art.
Um,
no,
uh,
yeah,
like,
you know,
did Kung Fu when I was like,
I think in third grade,
so I was pretty much qualified and do a
kick ass and space.
Didn't she kick you pretty hard a couple of times?
Yeah.
Yup.
She did.
You know,
she's got these,
she had got these,
she's really very powerful athlete and uh,
and a lot,
you know,
people don't understand that power does come from brute strength.
That comes from grace and it comes from like clean lines.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like you see the most graceful,
um,
mixed martial arts fighters and they're not like big muscle heads.
They're actually like,
almost like ballerinas,
you know what I mean?
And she's a ballerina,
so she whacked me once in the ribs.
I think I'd push on it.
It hurts still.
So might be broken.
I don't know.
It's been like,
it's been like a year,
so I think she broke it.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
she was wearing these boots too.
They're kind of like high heel boots,
but like instead of having a healed,
they have a,
like a,
a thin like rubber hard sole at the bottom and then he'll,
there's,
they're kind of interesting like a triangle.
And then,
uh,
she sort of shorter drove that triangle,
I guess into my,
yeah,
I'd say through my diaphragm,
it more into my lung.
Uh,
yeah,
it was a good,
she just,
she whacked me good,
you know,
but it's kind of Nice because that's just
them saying,
do you want to wear your guard,
your safe guards?
No,
no,
no.
Oh my God,
I got it.
Yeah.
James Gunn,
this done coordinator,
everybody.
And I was like,
seriously Chris,
you don't want to wear it.
Are you sure?
He's like,
come on.
It's like we know we know our marks and all right,
well,
so are you not supposed to make actual contact?
No,
you usually you,
you don't,
you're not supposed to.
And and
Ben does.
When you work with them,
when you work with someone like James,
he'll go like,
well you need to just get a little closer.
Just get a little closer.
Like looking at
kind of like you're blaming James and me for like not wearing some protective
shield.
Look,
the thing is is when it's,
when got winds,
people do stunts and when you do physical activities you just get bumps and
bruises.
And the fact that the fact that I got a one from Zoe is seems for some reason to
be remarkable because she's a female,
but she just happens to be another one of the people who did her own,
did a lot of her own stunts.
And so yeah,
you just get bumps and bruises when you do these things.
And,
and my ma the,
you know,
the funny,
tougher bump I got was her kicking me in the ribs.
Yeah.
Good to you.
Now you,
you,
there's a lot of talk about how in shape you got for this and how,
how I go on,
like be more specific.
What is
Zach?
You got you,
you buy,
I don't know,
you just got totally ripped,
uh,
you know,
Ms,
lot of universe style.
Um,
now do you now have to get back into comedy shape?
Is there,
is,
is there a comedy waiting to get to
Vidar?
I've been doing some extensive comedy weight training.
Yeah.
You want to train with actually,
yeah.
Train.
We can train.
You were good at right around in that good comedy.
Wait,
yeah,
I know.
I've,
yeah,
definitely started incorporating,
uh,
fun things and tasty things back into my life.
Um,
and I,
that's like just sort of the natural balance,
you know,
like you work very,
very hard,
but it really is,
you only live in that impeccable shape for maybe 24 hours.
No,
seriously.
It's like several months built up to like the,
it's like a,
it's like an orchid that blooms and dies on the same day.
You know,
it's like care and concern watering and the perfect amount of sunshine for six
months.
And then it just,
and you take a selfie
and then
you slowly,
the orchid falls off and,
and we're sucking in the whole movie pretty much.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
I have to say I'm,
Chris went through an arguous,
like in very strict,
uh,
I'm purposeful,
process transformation process that I had the gift of witnessing.
And he did it primarily for health reasons.
And you know,
he's a father as well,
so he wants to be a good example,
not just to his family,
but also to people out there that it is possible.
You could do it.
You could be the guy,
the Chubby guy from Parkson rags
and [inaudible] show on NBC
where he wrote in a marvel movie.
And it's just,
it's the message,
the positive message I had sent out,
where's my money?
I'm going to,
I'm going to go on that diet.
The
get cast in a huge blockbuster.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's a good one.
Now you're going to do a nude scene diet?
Probably anybody.
Uh,
w when I open up to questions,
anybody come in to work working out thing is you have to do that all the time.
Imagine.
Do you,
I mean,
is it like he for you,
is it like his process of like,
it's the one day,
but it's perfect for everyone?
In some ways it is to me you're always building to a specific scene you building
to a specific
fight scene,
whether it's,
you know,
and the thing or whether it,
yeah.
And um,
Are you ever just like,
Hey,
just let me stay in the car the whole time?
I am like that.
I'm just,
I'd be in the car.
Rock is out there.
I don't want to get down.
Stand next to him.
I don't want to slip on baby oil is,
so
that's the question.
Hi.
Uh,
speaking of baby oil,
um,
so,
uh,
Vin Mr Diesel,
I don't know if we want to be in a first name basis or nine right now.
We are.
Okay.
Sweet.
So a vin diesel,
Zoe Saldana,
both of you have been action figures before for Chris.
I don't know if there was a parks and rec action figure,
but maybe this is the first time you're an actual like action figure that's out
there and kids play with.
So one,
what's that feel like in too?
Have you ever played with yourself?
[inaudible] nice job by the way.
Yeah,
my,
my son was at target and somehow found a group doll.
And then when my daughter wanted to one day said they were sold out and they
didn't have any of the targets and became a big deal.
And uh,
it's a strange thing when you see a doll of yourself,
it's very twilight zone.
You imagine,
you know,
going to brush your teeth at night and opening up the cabinet and seeing nothing
but Groot dolls.
It's freaky.
It's a real freaky thing that's see a doll of yourself.
I mean,
especially if you're a tree.
Okay.
Now how did you guys were,
who were you acting with?
Was it like a tennis ball thing or for,
for group and a,
um,
what's the Fox guy's name?
What's that guy's name?
The rack hawks.
Ratko in,
sorry to hear rock.
He would he blow your
hello
a hole in your face?
Um,
no,
no.
You see like,
it really like it,
the tech like the way it works technically.
And not to bore you with all the w what it takes to,
no one's going to be bored by technical stuff.
That's,
yeah,
I guess it's probably,
it's probably true to it is pretty fascinating.
You know,
it really depends on what the,
what the seat with a shot was.
A would depend,
uh,
would,
would determine what we were acting opposite.
So if we're doing a closeup of Gomorrah and she's having an emotional scene and
with group where she looks at him and she's like having a real interaction and
we need to capture that,
capture that magic,
you know,
right here,
then you'll have her,
uh,
acting opposite.
An actor who do you need to be Christian who played the role of gruit on set or
Sean Gunn,
who has another role in the film is Craig Lynn.
It's hilarious.
Yeah,
he's really great.
And,
uh,
James guns,
brother Shawn,
he had great,
so good.
And,
and you know,
those characters were definitely born there on the stages when we were working.
And they,
those guys have had,
you know,
pretty thankless,
thankless job and there's sort of the unsung heroes of the movie because they
were there every single day in and out creating this stuff.
Really just so that we could have organic performance is opposite them.
So like when you go in for those money shots,
those magic emotional moments where you're having,
like for instance,
a quill is reacting to,
to rock,
and when he sees them in the prison for the first time and he's like,
you sees the cybernetic enhancements on his back,
he sees it.
This is a creature that's not,
not just,
uh,
tough,
you know,
little little guy with a machine gun,
but actually like a living,
breathing creature who feels stuff and who's like probably lonely.
Like you,
you develop empathy.
And that's all because I'm watching Sean walking into essentially create that
performance just so that I can react to it.
So like depending on the in and then sometimes you'd have like an led light or
an eyeline or if it's a big wide shot we might have,
it wasn't nothing.
We don't have some tennis balls.
Every,
there was time for tennis balls.
Yeah.
And Tim Times.
Chris has his own tennis ball and I had my own tennis ball and they had separate
trailers.
They kind of didn't get along and so I tennis balls and I get along.
Yeah,
we'd have different islands.
So like if,
if this plant didn't exist right here and we need to look like we're looking at
it,
I'd be looking at the young lady here in the black and in rose dress in between
those two individuals and I'd be looking somewhere over there
and grew.
It would be licking his shoulder.
Now when you were,
when you were watching this stuff,
were they like,
did you accidentally here are the other guys I am?
Groups were like during those off
never.
I never heard any I am Groot.
I just,
it was just wide open.
It was a really special experience for me because I was able to take my kids
into the Adr booth.
And so my kids were,
even before I saw the movie,
My kids were already imitating both of them.
Literally,
my three year old son was saying,
star Lord,
man.
Yeah,
I mean it was at,
my daughter runs around acting like she's Kamora now and they already know each
other.
So it's,
it's a surreal thing.
Such a good experience.
Such a,
it's one of those,
you all saw the movie.
Oh,
see,
you all saw this move.
What did you think in the movie?
[inaudible]
call it a gift movie.
I call it a gift movie because you have to gift it to someone.
You want to share it with someone.
You want to take every kid in your neighborhood.
Did this movie
[inaudible]
first of all on guardians too.
Okay,
thanks.
That's awesome.
Alrighty.
So my question is,
when you came in a bit later,
so is the press junket really how you're getting to know these guys and are you
going to be doing
onset stuff for two or a very,
very good question.
Uh,
I've known Zoe for many years.
Um,
so it was,
Zoe was kind of a comfort zone coming into this.
I directed a web series at some of the episodes of a web series at Venn created
called the ropes.
My sister and I were,
were directed three or four episodes of that.
So that's how we know Ben and his family.
And Chris,
I met on the Junket,
I met,
I met Brad,
I met Chris before I met Bradley Cooper.
I mean I literally,
I met Bradley Cooper backstage at one of the talk shows and uh,
but I felt like I knew him because I saw him in the Adr booth and I'm playing
off of them.
But it is surreal.
It's,
it's kind of a,
I play a tree.
I mean I guess there are no rules tree without seeming wooden.
It's strange.
I guess I'm going for that wooden performance.
I mean I look at trees.
Did you got a sec guys?
You've seen the movie.
You have to tell me,
you look at trees a little bit different.
Not so well,
you're not so ashamed of your tree hugger parents anymore.
I mean it's a new world.
Did anyone planted tree after they saw the movie?
Not much to ask.
Let's take one from the,
a super nerdy one from the dory here.
Give every member of the team whatever weapons he or she wants.
Who would win in a battle royale slash hunger game scenario and why
taught us the puck?
Be constantly tossing the Avengers.
Now what?
Let's just make this,
who would win in a fight?
You guys are the Avengers.
Are We uh,
do we get to use our spaceship?
Yeah.
Cause cause iron man would be able to,
wouldn't be,
I mean like I think,
well he gets to wear his suit.
He gets to wear a suit.
Right?
So yeah,
I can only take like his girlfriend Natalie Portman.
Yes.
Does it take place on earth or in space?
In space.
We,
we win.
You would win the suit.
You,
you can,
well we have more.
Yeah,
we have,
I think,
well I think the deciding factor would probably be rocket because like he would,
you know,
he would take Tony Stark's shoot apart and like guild like a nuclear bomb out of
it or something.
And then they also have a god.
So yeah,
you would obviously dismantle Thor because,
uh,
we also have a god
that we would win,
but it's not
be the deadliest woman in the galaxy.
So it's true Susie thing that we would win because they're all human.
They all Taryn.
Um,
except for Thor and um,
you know,
we are,
well [inaudible] he's such a nice guy.
Rocket would kill Bruce Banner.
He would wait for the hope to stop like slippers,
banners,
throat and then it would be done.
You guys are writing a movie [inaudible] crossover.
They all die in the first three minutes.
I'm sorry.
[inaudible]
did you guys ever start like pitching ideas like that?
I thought this was a creative meeting.
You guys,
this is all testing really well,
thank you.
We throw around ideas,
we pitched ideas,
but you know,
they don't listen.
Guardians [inaudible] what do you think would happen?
Ready all at once.
Everyone goes,
I'm hooked on a feeling they want from the gentleman over there.
Um,
so I've heard you're really into dungeons and dragons,
so I have two questions.
What character do you play and would you be willing to join our group?
You know,
it's whenever anyone asks me to join their campaign,
there's a good old feeling I have where I feel like,
you know,
I'm not alone in the world.
Okay.
And it's okay to be a Dweeb.
Um,
I,
I played a lot of code and I played the,
my most famous character you might've read about,
which was my witch hunter,
my Haftarah,
which hunter?
The irony is I'm about to next month to a movie called the witch hunter.
Kind of freaky.
I didn't,
I never thought in a million years when I was rolling that 20 sided die 20
something years ago that Hollywood would make a movie about to which center.
But that's another story.
Um,
uh,
and yet how,
where are you playing in on the east coast?
Well,
we actually do it over video chat.
You are doing video chat?
Yeah.
So,
um,
we've got one guy down in,
uh,
North Carolina a and,
t we'll video in and are using modules.
It's mostly second edition rules,
but they have some holdovers from the first edition.
Um,
so yeah.
Okay.
Thinking about it,
I mean we played with
Arcana,
we played with everything.
I mean that's where the Whitsundays which under wasn't created by Gary Gygax
says,
you know,
it was an aftermarket books that we were trying to incorporate and create new
games and try to create the,
it was a special time.
D And d was a special time.
Yeah.
We might have to get into that.
I can get into that man.
Do you know that Gary Guy Jakks as
break out sessions?
I'll tell you later.
You,
um,
there's,
so try to look at,
you know,
the mythology of star Lord and it looks like there's a whole lot of different
stories and uh,
origins stuff.
Did you read everything you can get your hands on or were you like,
I'm just going to read,
I'm just going to read the words on the script when the camera's on.
No,
no,
no.
It was someone who was somewhere in between the two.
I like,
it wasn't like,
you know,
I think it takes a little bit for me,
and this is going to sound crazy,
but it was the same thing when I did,
uh,
the movie moneyball.
There's a book that it's based on,
and I remember reading the script and I was like,
this is just such a great version of this story.
I don't want to come into this questioning,
uh,
questioning the script.
I don't want to come in and say,
well,
you know,
in fact this,
this time is a little off cause it just works so well as a story.
I thought the same thing with the script.
Um,
a lot of the guardians of the galaxy,
the incarnations of the guardians of the galaxy,
it doesn't,
don't include star Lord,
like the ones that I had happened to coincidentally collected as a kid.
They didn't have a star Lord in them.
And so there were some Star-Lord comics out there.
But for me,
what was important,
what the thing that grabbed me in the script that in creating this character was
that he and I are kind of the same person.
I mean we're both born in 1979 so in 1988 we were nine years old and we are both
have all the same pop culture references and icons,
which for him is like his,
his,
it's who he is.
I mean he was,
he was taken away from Earth at nine years old and brought out into space and
given an opportunity to,
to be an adventurer and he's like sort of running from this traumatic thing that
happened to them.
And so what he wants to do is just create a hero that he wants people to think
that he is star Lord and all of the,
everything he knows about life is based on the movies that I watched as a kid.
The movie,
The music that I listened to,
the dance moves that I knew and it's like this kid,
this guy is basically what me is nine years old would want to be if I was given
carte blanche to be an adventure and space.
So that's where I started mining for information is like what did I like the
Kevin Bacon line that was,
that was a result of collaboration and footloose that was never in the script.
Like these things like that or like yeah cause I loved footloose and I was like,
when he's that says she won't dance,
maybe it should be this ideology like really loves movies is like the legends
that create him.
You know,
cause he's like,
he's gotten,
he hasn't been to earth since he was nine,
you know,
so he gets to kind of be whoever he wants to be.
So that's really where I started kind of developing or we collaborate,
collaborate in developing who this guy would be is just who I was at that age.
Yeah.
When Gomorrah says like,
just like Kevin Bacon,
think that was like the biggest
laugh.
Yeah.
That sounds amazing to that.
And I went in there cause I was waiting to hear a little foot on the soundtrack.
I was like there's that song.
Yeah,
no did you,
did they plan all those songs out?
Soundtrack is amazing.
Did you like know what the mix tape was going to be?
I knew,
yeah.
That was the first thing I requested after reading the script was I was like
Dora James,
send me this mix tape.
Because you know,
in the script he had written specifically each song that would play in each
scene.
And that lasted throughout from the first script,
from his first draft all the way to the end.
Like those songs were in there and planned.
So I made him send me the mix tape,
which includes all those songs plus many more.
Cause I figured,
you know,
if you have like one cassette tape and it's all you listened to for 20 years,
you're going to,
it's going to become part of you,
you know?
So I listened to that thing.
I mean no less than a hundred times,
but probably more than a hundred times.
Wow.
So in,
so in the SQL we're going to,
we're going to hear that second mix tape.
Yeah,
we'll hit they're awesome.
Mix Volume.
Phoenix.
There was no scene where you'd like trying to unwind it with the pencil.
Rewind.
I know
these guys have a really busy day.
Let's pick one more if we can.
Uh,
so
Sandoz has already been introducing Avengers and now he's been shown in
guardians.
Right.
So are there any plans already being made for teaming a boot,
the Avengers in the guardians?
Probably for the next version as
well.
James Gunn has talked about that already.
He's been pretty open about,
uh,
cross collaboration of Avengers.
And is that what you're asking?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what I think I would want to see.
I don't ever want to see the Guardian's fight the Avengers.
Yeah.
Um,
I want to see them sort of fighting together maybe against their nose because I
do believe that then I'll just sort of,
isn't the animals like the overall enemy of everybody,
right.
You don't know.
I think,
I think like,
isn't he your dad?
I want to go.
Right.
Like,
what I think is so cool about the guardians of the galaxy is it opens up the
universe.
So like instead of like taking these new things and bringing them right back to
the stories we already know,
I think it's like open it up like see what other corners of the galaxy we can
discover,
bring in characters like that weren't,
you know,
bringing in characters there were from some of the guardians of the Galaxy,
like explore yon to explore the art and the origins more of these characters.
And if it is thanatos explore the infinity gauntlet,
like how many of these stones is he going to get and who does that open up like
the universe expands,
you know,
and looking out on it,
we want to take these characters and bring them into the Avengers and we want to
like have them be all in the same movie together.
It's like,
no,
fuck that and make it fucking a hundred movies.
Do you know what I mean?
They ended up crossing over break
or are we out of time?
We are out of time officially.
Please stay our beloved guests for joining us.
[inaudible]
one more.
Why?
No post credits scene.
There is a post credit scene.
There is a post credit scene and it's not.
It's not going to be in any of the advanced screenings.
None of the press meetings,
hey,
don't groan.
You want the post credit scene?
It's going to cost you 13 bucks.
Yeah,
and see this and maybe a little more in Imax and you'll see it,
but I know what it is and no one else does.
Yes,
I do.
And it's going to blow your mind.
Go back.
Just go back to,
I'm going to sneak it into a theater at the end of it.
All right.
Once again,
thank you guys so much for joining us.
[inaudible].